we're at number 10
and uh the the last in uh
the manooches
gyaku means opposite side
kiyaku yokomen
so you know what these sheer ski is same
thing from the heart
but means you strike
the other side to what you have been
so
strike
same thing come to the end
you have all the same points as before
no hole with the hand these two
small finger the next finger are the
ones that grip
same with this hand
again turn or
sideways i suggest you try and both find
out what one you like
the teacher who's teaching at the time
they will criticize you if they don't
like
what you're doing if they like what
you're doing and they can see you're
doing something slightly different but
they like what you're doing
and more than likely let it go if
they're very fastidious
and that's you know want it done exactly
their way
they will tell you to do it their way
just modify it to keep them happy
but my advice is find who you are find
what suits you but don't make it so that
you
it's dangerous you have to look at all
the points
[Music]
again you can modify it to how you
enjoy doing the suburbs
you know you can do this type of thing
you need to look before you start
thrusting this is a weakness
turn and look first and then thrust
this one's very important and it's like
the third
sabui it must reach under the
if you hold with these two fingers your
hand won't distort
if you hold with all the fingers you get
this
this problem this bent
and then it's weak if you hold it with
just them two fingers
as long as you don't have this trigger
finger somebody pick up this
trigger we call it a trigger finger
because it's like firing a pistol isn't
it
or rifle that's why it's called trigger
finger
keep that out the way it doesn't have to
be tight but it has to be
out the way or else it could get broken
there's a gap there
so it's not solid and that will break
i saw cytosensor do this sometimes but
you always use to shout to us not to do
it so
i'm giving you the same advice don't do
as i do do as i tell you
it should sit under there comfortably
it should sit under the arm comfortably
it should rest there that's
that's when you know it's in the right
place it should rest there
as soon as you take your back hand off
once you grasp
if it doesn't rest there and there's a
little crook then it's
it's incorrect
this stepping forward and this pelvis
tip
makes that happen better
so
uh the window so i can't fully do it
with this
let it go past line with this
okay so there are the five
striking movements
so
[Music]
so that's the first 10. if i
think of things that i've forgotten
hopefully i haven't forgotten anything
but if i think of things i've forgotten
i will try to add them in on another
video okay
these are all the things i can think of
at the time while i'm doing it
please practice these over and over
again
check the video out don't just try and
rush through all the videos thinking
that you're going to gain all this
knowledge
it's taken me nearly 50 years i'm still
developing i'm still working on things
that i get wrong
it's not a big deal to me now i think oh
well i'm still getting it wrong
where i've got my high kilo career so
far
i've beat myself oh i'm still doing it
wrong with it
this doesn't help you enjoy your aikido
so enjoy your aikido
and we'll start with the next ten so
don't worry stuck